PLAY FOR A TEAM THAT IS MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION.
I THINK THOSE TWO TEAMS PROBABLY
STOOD OUT.
>> HOW ABOUT WHAT WENT ON OR DID
NOT GO ON WITH THE LOS ANGELES
LAKERS TODAY?
>> YEAH.
IT WAS TOUGH.
THEY DON'T HAVE MANY ASSETS.
WE ALL KNEW THAT.
THEY HAD ONE TREASURE ASSET AND
NOBODY IN HIS PLACE.
YOU CAN'T TRADE HIM AND THEY
WERE STUCK IN THAT REGARD.
I WAS TOLD SOURCES INFORMED ME
THAT THE ROCKETS DID REACH OUT
TO THE LAKERS TO OFFER JOHN WALL
FOR RUSSELL WESTBROOK BUT THEY
WANTED THE LAKERS TO INCLUDE A
FIRST ROUND PICK.
THE LAKERS DECLINED THAT.
SO THAT WAS THE END OF THAT
DISCUSSION RIGHT THERE.
SO AS FAR AS THAT GOES, THERE
WAS REALLY NOT MUCH MORE THAT
THE LAKERS COULD DO, SO THIS
TEAM IS STANDING PAT.
SOURCES INFORM ME THEY ARE GOING
TO GO INTO THE BUY-OUT MARKET'
SEE WHAT CAN BE DONE THERE.
BUT IT'S STILL LOOKING DIM THERE
AS FAR AS BRINGING IN SOMEBODY
THAT IS GOING TO HELP AN
TRANSITION THEM INTO A TEAM WE
ALL THOUGHT WAS GOING TO BE A
CONTENDING TEAM.
>> ME AND KENNY MADE A BET ABOUT
A MONTH AGO THAT THE LAKERS ARE
GOING TO WIN SIX GAMES IN A ROW.
ARE YOU RIDING WITH ME OR ARE
YOU RIDING WITH KENNY?
>> SO KENNY SAID THEY WERE
WINNING SIX IN A ROW?
>> YES, HE DID, ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
>> I'M ROLLING WITH YOU, CHUCK!
>> STILL EARLY.
>> STILL EARLY?
>> WE ARE NOT AT THE MIDWAY
POINT.
>> WE ARE MORE THAN 50 GAMES IN!
>> YOU GO RIDE WITH KENNY?
THEY WIN SIX IN A ROW?
>> I'M NOT SAYING THEY ARE
WINNING A CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> YOU'RE A GOOD MAN